ça lui permet de se réorganiser et
d'échapper au coup du Nord en passant
vers le sud et euh si vous voulez je
pense que le Hamas il a gagné ce qu'il
avait à gagner maintenant il le gagne
comme on le dit sur l'image sur les
présentations et cetera mais la guerre
contre Israël pour l'instant il a pas
besoin de la continuer le 7 octobre pour
lui ça a été suffisant ce qu'il gagne en
image aujourd'hui c'est suffisant il
faut préserver les forces vous savez
c'est un groupe terroriste les groupes
terroristes ça fait quoi ça frappe et ça
dis paraî parce qu'ils ne peuvent pas
s'opposer à une armée comme l'armée de
salahal qui est très puissante he et
donc on passera à une autre phase que je
connais pas bien est-ce que c'est dans
un an dans 2 ans est-ce que c'est le
hzbollah au Liban je ne sais pas mais le
tout du Hamas a gagné aujourd'hui le
fait que vraiment les Palestiniens se
rallent de plus en plus au Hamas même si
quand on est dans Gaza et qu'on a connu
la main de fer du Hamas les gens
ne sont pas contents de ce qui se passe
mais en sjordanie où le has ne règne pas
et là il est en train de gagner en
puissance donc on voit que le Hamas est
gagnant dans cette affaire là grâce à
Monsieur netaniah vous diriez que c'est
une poudrière qui est en train de
s'installer auus de la bande de Gaza on
imagine des conditions extrêmement
compliquées pour les gens qui ont été
déplacés bien sûr c'est très très très
compliqué et vous voyez tout ce qui
manque là-dedans c'est une
perspective on appelle dans TER
militaire l'effet final recherché
qu'est-ce que veut monsieur netaniaou il
dit anniilation du Hamas je vous l'ai
dit mission impossible donc casser
réduire le Hamas très bien mais quel est
l'objectif après alors tous américains
européens disent l'objectif après c'est
un État palestinien la sécurité d'Israël
ne reposera que sur le fait qu'il y a un
État palestinien mais en ayant monté le
Hamas qui lui ne veut pas d'état
d'Israël on éloigne cette perspective et
puis après ce qui s'est passé c'est le 7
octobre pour la population israélienne y
compris la population des kibuts qui
était plutôt des gens pacifiques qui
voulit un État palestinien ça s'éloigne
donc on est vraiment dans dans une
espèce d'impasse politique parce que
aucune perspective politique n'a été
définie alors le gouvernement israélien
a décidé de débloquer 100 millions de
dollars supplémentaires en faveur des
colonies en Cisjordanie quel est le but
de c'est la poursuite de la politique
complètement suicidaire de Monsieur
netanahou je rappelle que ces colonies
sont totalement illégales qui a eu
plusieurs résolutions qui ont été votées
là-dessus RA certains ministres ouai
tout le monde tout le monde est contre
ça alors si vous voulez moi j'allais
dire s'il sortent le carnet check et
bien création d'un État palestinien
suppression et ça est très dur parce que
les les colons sont prê à se défendre
avec leurs armes suppression des
colonies et carnet check de l'Arabie
Saoudite des émirats qui est pas
pardonnez-moi mais un peu plus épais que
celui d'Israël parce que il y a que
comme ça qu'on peut s'en tier mais on
est dans une situation difficile qui va
se régler difficilement et dans la durée
et qui ne se règlera pas sans des pleurs
et des grincements de dents comme il est
écrit dans la Bible on on sur la suite
de la trêve il a le ministre des
Affaires étrangères du Qatar il dit
notre objectif principal à l'heure
actuelle est notre espoir est de
parvenir à une trêve durable qui mènera
de nouvelles négociations et finalement
à la fin de la guerre on peut y croire à
ça écoutez on est vraiment dans le court
terme là tous les efforts sont faits
là-dessus je répète pardonnez-moi je
cite toujours netanahou mais il y a que
lui qui est contre ça enfin lui et puis
c'est c'est sidin euh tout mais qui peut
qui peut le faire plier est-ce que le
Qatar peut le faire plier est-ce que
Anthony blinken qui doit retourner en
Israël dans les prochains jours le
secrétaire d'État américain peut le
faire plier politiquement monsieur
netanahou est mort sauf que comme tous
ces personnes parce que ça dure depuis
plusieurs années il a été plusieurs fois
ministre et cetera et cetera il joue sa
survie il devrait comprendre qu'il est
mort et s'il avait un peu l'intérêt de
l'État et non pas l'intérêt personnel
l'intérêt de l'État il s'éloignerait
pour laisser d'autres personnes qui sont
dans son gouvernement aujourd'hui et qui
sont plus capables de négocier et je
vais pas me mettre à place des
Israéliens pour négocier surtout après
ce qui s'est passé le 7 octobre faut
revenir à ce choc absolument ma
mais il faut revenir à la suite de
politique depuis 30 ans c'est-à-dire je
le rappelle l'assassinat de Monsieur
Rabine par des Israéliens sont pas les
Palestiniens qui tué sont les Israéliens
donc il y a un moment où si vous voulez
l'État d'Israël que je connais un peu
j'ai commandé un bataillon au Liban j'ai
été à l'époque où Israël occupait le sud
Liban l'État d'Israël doit comprendre
qu'il ne peut pas malgré le choc de la
Choa le choc du 7 octobre de ces poogrom
il ne peut pas exister contre tout le
monde il faut qu'il existe avec les
autres les accords d'Abraham qui ont été
signé qui ont été probablement un des
déclencheurs de la site du 7 octobre
puisque l'Arabie Saoudite se préparait à
signer les accords d'abrahams avaient
ignorer la Palestine c'était une grave
faute de Monsieur Trump mais il avait
dit l'économie va pouvoir sauver les
choses ben reprenons les accords
deabahams en laissant une place à la
Palestine en laissant un finance pour la
Palestine et peut-être qu'on va changer
les choses mais ça c'est facile à dire
comme ça dans un studio parisien sur le
terrain dans le cœur des gens c'est
extrêmement compliqué dans le cœur des
Palestiniens qui sont bafoués depuis des
années et dans le cœur des israéliens
qui ont vu ce qui s'est passé le 7
octobre extrêmement compliqué de
rapprocher ces
extrêmes